[Musica]
ragazzi avete sentito scusate se sono al
buio e se parlo a bassa voce ma sono
nascosta dentro l'armadio vedete per non
farmi vedere da grande questa nuova
challenge dovrò giocare a nascondino con
i cattivi più cattivi di tutti e ci
saranno quattro turni quindi quattro
round
io ho solo due vite
quindi devo cercare di non essere prese
più di due volte
altrimenti perderò la cia come avete
visto la prima challenge è con granny io
sono nascosta dentro questo armadio ma
sto aspettando che si distragga così
posso andare magari nascondermi sopra
letto perché ho paura che si metta a
controllare dentro gli armadi mi
raccomando lasciato un bel mi piace se
volete altre solvency con i cattivi se
questo video raggiunge i 30 mila mi
piace se sarà un'altra sala ed con i
cattivi anzi consigliati mi vuoi che
altre sale ci vuole vedere nel canale
tour nei commenti siete pronti prendete
i pop corn aiuto ma cercando
aiuto
ok forse stava uscendo dalla porta
e uscito
la poiché approfittiamone per andare ad
hoc è i ragazzi eccomi qua sono nel mio
nascondiglio preferito sopra al letto a
castello è il mio preferito perché ho
un'ottima visuale da qua e in genere non
mi scoprono qua ma se avete visto le mie
attrici anni in su sapete che a volte è
andata a finire male comunque
eccola la porta
e andata verso lo armati per fortuna
sono il sito davi
sta avvicinando qua perché mi nascondo
di tiro qualche pupazzo così forse
ancora tira se sente il rumore sapete
che i treni e cieca tiriamo tiriamo
quale sacrifico vediamo come è andata a
rincorrerlo che berlino per qua no no no
no senso unico non farle capire che sono
quattro merrill ha preso il pupazzo
lascia lascerò bravo a non prenderlo ok
gremi se n'è andata forse è meglio che
scendo da fare
marino fa silenzio mi raccomando ok
ragazzi sono scelta dal letto ora vado
subito fuori dalla porta
così posso trovare un altro nascondiglio
a berlino marino ha preso il pupazzo
nola sono berlino pensiamo bravo bravo
merlino anche se marino vorrebbe il
pupazzo però da berlino no no no no no
[Musica]
non ho già perso una vita il primo turno
lo già perso grenier bravissima a
giocare a nascondino
anche se insomma le sue intenzioni non
penso che siano proprio di giocare non
so chi altro stia venendo a cercarmi
adesso tra i cattivi
quindi devo subito sbrigarmi il car e un
nascondiglio di uscire dallo studio e
andiamo mirino di strano
chi
ok sono riuscite a nascondermi qua in
camera provate e andato di là
berlino mi sta guardando male non so
perché che c'è berlino che c'è mi aveva
visto ok
dormivo aiuto ma so se scappare
chiuso la porta ma che sta facendo rota
ci sarà porta e ora mi sta fissando come
se fosse un gelato al caramello
ok forse meglio scappare mi è venuta
un'idea roth ha paura del caldo perché è
una sorta di mega gelato gigante no
quindi se io esco vuoi siccome c'è
caldissimo in questi giorni perché siamo
in estate
potrei portarlo al sole vi sareste
riesco scioglierlo diventerò il turno
[Musica]
eccolo vieni pure rod vini pure qua al
sole e al caldo e pure qua non sta
facendo effetto sbaglio forse devo
andare più al sole in i rod rincorri mi
vieni pure qua
si sta scritto da funzionando si sta
sciogliendo era il momento per me di
scappare addio
ciao ciao uomo gelato poi abbiamo
abbiamo vinto questo secondo turno
passiamo al terzo turno
[Applauso]
[Musica]
e penso che scenderò al piano di sotto
con berlino se mi seguirà merlino ma
stiamo molto attenti perché il prossimo
cattivo che non so chi può essere si
potrebbe nascondere in ogni angolo
quindi tenete gli occhi bene aperti
pechino
mi sembra che ci sia nessuno
abbiamo perso la casetta uno dei nostri
nascondigli preferiti dai andiamo marino
andiamo nella casetta
ok
in più
finiture berlino
vieni fuori nella nostra casetta che c'è
chi c'e berlino berlino ha visto
qualcosa forse non ti litro
ecco la berlina è tornato nella casetta
che stai facendo merlino che c'è
qualcuno là sotto non penso che un
motivo posso stare là sotto c'è premi e
gradino sotto i gremi 2 il nonno marino
non andare lì e non andare da grandi
eccolo lì lo vedete
berlino non leccarla porta
sto aspettando che io esca dalla casetta
ma io non sarò mai da quaggiù marino che
ne pensi di probabili la mazza ma non lo
vedo
siamo riusciti a vincere anche questo
round visto che è scappato andiamo fino
a rimanere nella casetta dalle mani pure
lì io esco
[Musica]
[Applauso]
hanno grandi 2 il nonno mi ha preso
quindi ho perso il terzo turno questo il
quarto e ultimo turno ma non ho più vite
disponibili quindi se perdo questo turno
avrà perso la challenge quindi stiamo
super attenti è arrivato marino ad
aiutarmi
non so chi sia il prossimo cattivo oddio
[Musica]
il secondo scontarsi subito
non lo so forse qua non mi vede avete
riconosciuto chi è se non l'avete vista
bene ora la vedrete perché sta entrando
[Musica]
come fatto già e rino devi spostarti da
quattro nidi arriva ma scomparsa
fondo di fantasma berlino berlino lascia
spazzatura ok lasciando sofferto sono
sotto al letto
spero che annabelle mi vedrà qua sotto
a meno che non si avvicini marino a
smith armi e cosi scoprira che sono qua
io berlino berlino la sta distraendo
bravo merlino fondo la via su fondo la
via mandano via
bravo veroli non sono io
grazie primissimo grazie o merlino ho
vinto l'ultimo turno il quarto turno è
sempre la mia guardia del corpo berlino
ma se volete vedere un altro episodio di
nascondino con i personaggi cattivi che
la prossima volta saranno altri
personaggi cattivi
forse più cattivi e ancora più
inquietanti e paurosi lasciò di un bel
mi piace se questo video raggiungere i
30 mila mi piace si sarà la seconda
parte del nascondino pauroso e ora vi
lascio qua 4s l'innesco cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri video che quadrati
prevede